We are approaching
the end of day eight.
Students are still working.
Today is the first day that
they're off on their own.
I didn't record a
confessional last night,
because I sort of forgot to.
But yesterday was the last
official day of lecture.
It was on post-production.
That's been a challenge to
balance context, and sort
of the more bigger
picture digital literacy,
understanding the medium
type things with just
the practical things
that they need
to know to do their project.
And given a small
amount of time,
there's always been a
compromise of something.
Yesterday was great.
I think when I heard
Josh read his script,
it was one of my favorite
moments in class.
First of all, his idea
had come such a long way.
And his delivery
was very good, too,
and he said that he had watched
Andrea from the day before,
and tried to pick
up tips from her.
I'm happy with this community
of students that have
come together for this class.
And I think, in part, a
lot of that has happened
because it's small enough.
Seeing them pair off to
work on their projects,
they have really helped
each other a lot.
And certain personalities
have come through that
were super quiet in class.
Jamie and I were very deliberate
with how we grouped people up
for their final projects.
It's been hard to balance the
practical skills with context.
I sent out this midpoint survey
to the students yesterday,
and someone had said
it was really, really
packed the first week, and all
of a sudden, the pressure's
been released.
If I could find a better way
to spread out all that stuff,
I think it'd be more ideal.
Oh, the other thing
is, thinking about how
this could be a
scalable experience,
I can't imagine this class
going over ten people.
And I think the thing
that's been most valuable
is individual feedback.
And I might have
mentioned this before,
but you can easily
teach best practices.
You can easily talk
about techniques.
You can even show the examples.
You can go from
concept to example,
and people can acknowledge
that and people can
critique other peoples' work.
But then transferring
it to the final layer
of being self-aware enough
and self-reflective enough
to view your work with
that same critical eye,
and, in some sense, like
being able to cultivate taste
among people is really hard.
I don't know if I'm
really doing it.
And who am I to say that I have
the best taste in anything?
A lot of the times questions are
posed, opening with, Is it OK?
Is it OK if I do this?
Is it OK if I change this?
Is it OK if I go
to this location?
I know that what they're
trying to ask is,
do you recommend this?
But it's just, it's
striking the way
that's so ubiquitously posed.
I don't want the
mentality to be that I
am sort of the end-all be-all.
I think, more than anything, I'd
want the self-awareness though.
If someone made a terrible
video, but they could say,
I think this is bad,
and I think maybe this
is why, I think that that's
ultimately where we need to be.
More self-awareness in
science communication.